- [Voiceover] Let's give
ourselves some practice
adding mixed numbers.
So let's say I want to add
two, let me write it this way.
Let's say I want to add
two and four sevenths
plus three and two sevenths,
three and two sevenths.
I encourage you to pause this video
and try to think about
what this is going to be.
Well there's a couple of ways
that you could tackle it.
One way, you could say, well let me just
add the nonfraction parts.
You could say that two plus
three is equal to five,
and then you could say that
four sevenths plus two sevenths
is equal to well four
sevenths plus two sevenths
is gonna be equal to six sevenths.
Hey, wait, wait, wait, how
did I, how did I do that?
How did I just only add the fraction parts
or add the whole parts?
Well the way I did that is because
two and four sevenths is the same thing
as two plus four sevenths.
Two and four sevenths, same
thing as two plus four sevenths.
And then plus three and two
sevenths is the same thing
as three plus two sevenths,
so all I did over here,
two and four sevenths
plus three and two sevenths,
is two plus four sevenths
plus three plus two sevenths.
And you can swap the
order in how this happens.
So you could take, you
could just switch the order
and say this is going to be
two plus three, two plus three,
plus four sevenths, plus two sevenths.
And what we just figured out was that
two plus three is equal
to five, right over here,
and that four sevenths plus two sevenths
is equal to six sevenths, just like that.
Now let's do a more interesting example.
Let's do, let's say that I
have three and three fifths,
three and three fifths
plus five and four fifths.
Now what is this going to be equal to?
Well if you do the same technique,
if you add the three plus the five,
you're going to get eight,
and then if you add the three
fifths plus four fifths,
you would get seven fifths.
So you get eight and seven fifths.
And this wouldn't be wrong.
This is eight and seven fifths,
if you add these two things together,
but it's a little bit strange here
because seven fifths
is bigger than a whole.
So to get a better sense of what number's
really being represented here,
I want to rewrite this.
So eight and seven fifths,
this is the same thing as eight plus,
and instead of seven fifths,
we could say this is the
same thing as five fifths,
which is a whole, plus two fifths.
Now why is that interesting?
Because five fifths, notice
five fifths plus two fifths,
that's seven fifths right over there.
Or you can consider five fifths to be one,
so this is eight plus one, which is nine,
and two fifths, nine and two fifths.
So all I did here, I added it the same way
that I did the first
problem a few seconds ago.
But when I realize this fraction
part is greater than one,
I separated it into
one and then a fraction
that is less than one,
and that whole, I was able to add
to the eight to get to nine,
and then I would have
two fifths left over.
Eight and seven fifths,
because five fifths is a whole,
is the same thing as nine and two fifths.
So if I wanted to write this
in, I guess, a clearer way,
I would say this is nine and two fifths.
Three and three fifths
plus five and four fifths
is nine and two fifths,
and once again, we say wait,
three plus five is only eight,
how did I get a nine?
Well that's because three
fifths plus four fifths
is greater than one.